no justice Cassandra Greene demands
justice for four african-americans
murdered 70 years ago every year Green
directs a reenactment of a lynching
which took place in 1946 at Moores Ford
bridge in the southern US state of
Georgia
the killers have never been identified
can green break through the wall of
silence that still surrounds the case
we're not going to just sit back and
just continue to see people die and not
do anything this is doing something
y'all this is sending a statement this
is giving a message that it's not
acceptable it wasn't acceptable in 1946
it's not acceptable in 2016 hello
somebody
okay so then that's why we're here
that's why we do what we do and so I'm
just asking you guys as usual you know
it's emotional so I want you to just
sort it you know try to keep each other
you know love on each other you know
it's okay once a year a group of actors
gathers at the first African Baptist
Church in Monroe a small town in Georgia
near Atlanta the majority of the
residents here are white some may have
witnessed the crime committed decades
ago but they remain silent
Cassandra Greene is filling bags with
fake blood they'll be used later today
when she and the actors reenact the
lynching I'm just thinking trying to get
them to push push it up here in that few
seconds at the end that that the
Klansmen are in you think it'll be
enough time together squeeze it up out
of everywhere well okay so that's
Cassandra Greene has herself been
threatened by the Ku Klux Klan
once a Klansmen stood outside her front
door with a weapon at the ready she
spent the night lying on the floor
paralyzed with fear yeah okay okay so we
will figure it out we'll figure it out
okay we're definitely not welcome that's
for sure and we know that we've learned
that over the years so so I'm totally
thinking about the entire killing of
George memory Dorothy and Roger every
second that I'm here every second I'm
here
in addition to her work as a director
the rest of Cassandra Greene's life
revolves around activism I haven't had a
date in 16 years
take a guess I don't have a proper life
I have no life in the church someone
makes an emotional appeal for justice in
the case no justice the reenactment
begins with an argument that will end in
murder back in 1946 Roger Malcolm was
involved in an argument with a white man
the scene uses language that was typical
in the deep south at the time after the
confrontation Malcolm was arrested he
was later bailed out by his employer who
then drove Malcolm his wife and another
black couple home they were stopped on
the road by an angry crowd and this is
how this story began with the stabbing
of Barnett Hester by Roger Malcolm it's
not going to disappear we're not going
to disappear we're here we'll we'll be
here until there's some type of resolve
and it's not about dividing it's about
bringing reconciliation but you can't
bring reconciliation without truth so
the truth needs to be told and someone
needs to be accountable after the
meeting in the church the actors drive
to the sites where the original events
took place
okay put your PIN inside Cassandra gives
the actors some last-minute instructions
most of the audience's come from out of
town including motorcycle clubs and
civil rights activists
none of Monroe's white residents are in
attendance
an actor is delivering a speech made by
Eugene Talmadge a Georgia governor in
the 1930s and 40s and a vigorous
advocate of segregation
this year the fewer the better but I'll
say this if I'm elected your governor
they won't vote in our democratic white
primary in the next four years we asked
the actor who played Thomas why no white
locals are here for the performance but
why people don't like to be reminded of
this sort of thing we like to pretend
that we like to pretend that the
lynchings and the racist terror that was
conducted in the south was the product
of some ugly minority that had nothing
to do with the mainstream of white
society and that's simply a lie the
truth of the matter is that racist
terrorism was an intrinsic part of the
political structure of the south
following the fall of reconstruction
right up until 1964 and everyone who was
in the white community who did not stand
up against it forcefully and which was
the majority of people they did not were
complicit either actively or by omission
in these crimes and no one wants to
confront that fact
now the actors head for the actual scene
of the crime more's Ford bridge just
outside of town
despite rain the reenactment continues
those involved are not just concerned
about what happened here 70 years ago
they're also concerned about the racism
that they experienced almost daily okay
you guys can get a position
can I please make sure everyone has the
street right here clear a white mob
blocked the street and stop the car in
which the two black couples were
traveling wait you gonna have to come up
to them here okay just because of where
we are stay above white man boy
you're gonna die you never catch a white
man
yeah the strange
little
dude black body swinging from the
popular tree
many of the people here are still
outraged by these murders they want to
put a stop to the discrimination even
the hatred that they experience every
day at the hands of the local white
residents these people will do anything
in order to keep the status quo they do
not want you up after 6 o'clock in
Monroe and Walton County here will be
stand it's time for me to get ready to
go home today Cassandra Greene has not
managed to get through to white people
who live in Monroe but she says she will
keep fighting for justice for those who
were murdered at Moore's Ford bridge
they literally died in the spot where we
were so when you think about the fact
that five people lost their lives in
that little spot it's very painful for
me so it's very emotional I feel like
I'm not doing enough this is not enough
we really need someone to come forward
and say something just just for the
family you know what I'm saying just
just to give them a piece about what
happened right in that spot on July 25th
1946